where would negative 17 six or so
negative 17 / 6 go on this number line
and for me I like to think of it as a
mixed number so with the way I like to
think about it this is the same thing as
negative 17 / 6 and so you can rewrite
it as negative 17 / 6 is the same thing
well six line we can do it over here six
goes into well we could say six goes
into 17 and then add the negative later
we're going to get a negative value here
but six goes into 17 two times let me
write that too in a new color is goes
into 17 exactly two times and then 2
times 6 is 12 you subtract 17-12 you get
five so you end up with a remainder five
so negative 17 / 6 this is going to be
negative to a negative divided by
positive is a negative negative 2 and
then a remainder of 5 so it's negative 2
and 5 negative 2 and five six so all
I've done is converted this improper
fraction into a mixed number and now
that makes it easier for me to plot so
when I plot it let me make sure what
each of these little each of these
little Mark's are so if I have one two
three marks I'm at negative 3 1 2 3
marks a bit positive 3 so each of these
must be 1 so this must be one too this
should be negative 1 negative 2 so we're
going to go negative 2 and five six so
this is so let's keep this is negative 1
then we keep going we go to negative 2
now we have to go another negative 5 6
so that's almost another negative 1 so
it's another negative 56 it's going to
get us right about right about there I
could actually do a bunch of hash marks
1 2 3 4 5 and then 66 would be a whole
one so negative 56 would be five of
these which is once again right over
there so negative 2 and 5 6 puts us
right over there that's where I'd place
it